as we reported about seven million
people live in Harley's path and they
are going to need help in the days weeks
and possibly even months to come
Stephanie arking angel is a spokesperson
for the American Red Cross which is
already mobilizing efforts to help the
victims she joins us on the phone
Stephanie good morning good morning
it's Stephanie give us some sense this
is nothing new for the Red Cross but
where are you preparation rides and
starting to mobilize those efforts
you know our efforts efforts have been
mobilized already we have more than 24
shelters open we're sheltering more than
1,400 people and that's a real
conservative effort we had supplies come
into the area yesterday to support more
than 20,000 people who may need our help
so the Red Cross has been on the ground
we are opening shelters as needed and
we're going to be bringing in more
support and more supplies in the days to
come this is going to be a long effort
Stephanie if you had any reports yet of
damage or injuries or anything like that
I do not have that information now we
haven't had any of those reports yet
it's definitely it always seems that
people are wondering what they can do
even if they are not close to the storm
in some way to help out it's early but
what advice would you give you know well
volunteers are always going to be needed
all of the time and the depends on
finances to be able to provide relief
immediately and people can help by
texting the word Carvey to nine zero
nine nine nine to make it $10 donating
how long an effort are you preparing for
down there Stephanie we are preparing
for the long haul
as we know disasters are chaotic and
they're unpredictable and Carvey is
going to dump a lot of moisture here and
Texas is going to be floated for a while
so we are prepared to shelter and help
people for as long as needed
can you give us any sense I know it is
early but what this may compare to as
far as other disaster relief maybe other
hurricane relief you know Ystad after is
different and every time
unexpected things happened and so really
the focus is on what is happening right
here now with Harvey and right here in
Texas and that's where our focus area is
now and so what is your biggest concern
then there right now our biggest concern
is making sure that everyone has the
shelter that they need that people are
evacuating and what we're doing is
working with our local emergency
management our local government
officials and community partners to make
sure that we have those shelters open
and that people have a safe place to
stay and a warm meal to eat
it's definitely Arcangelo over the Red
Cross thanks very much for joining with
us this morning
and stay with CBS News as we bring you
continuing coverage of hurricane Harvey
throughout the day on this CBS station
and on our digital streaming service CBS
and